[Music]
How are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief news report on Kirchner in
Spanish. New details related to the
attack at a nightclub that
involved the New Orleans Saints player.
The benchmark is a case that
our investigative team is
closely following.  another
nfl player has a warrant after being part of
this incident
las vegas metropolitan police said you think the hand of
the kansas city chiefs is the fourth
suspect in this attack
earlier this week authorities
arrested two men for  the beating
at grey's inside the as prior to
the February 6 robbery at the leader stadium
when
a 32-year-old man who
gave a 13-year-old girl pills and
died went to jail marquès crawley
He accepted the charges for
voluntary manslaughter with the use of a deadly weapon
and rapid sexual coercive measures, he
will spend 7 to 20 years in prison and is
registered as an abu  sexual abuser he will be
formally sentenced in april and
construction of a complex
for the elderly has already begun this
project is located near histrión
in washington the first phase will consist
of 60 units and has a cost of
approximately 19 million dollars
the city  from las vegas and
county subsidies are working together to
offer services upon completion of this
project scheduled for next year and
keep your coat handy because
we will have cold days and nights here in the
valley despite clear skies
with highs in the  sixties
a sunny weekend awaits us with
temperatures in the 70s but then you can
see the cold returns for next
week I am cristian cásseres with shadow
ignition informative spanish good day